[Music]
to transform myself into RAD school I
had to chop off my nose my ears and have
suit dermal implants
the eyes were
the most impactful the next day I woke
up and went to the bathroom to wash
myself
and when I was my face and look up in
the mirror
it really struck me you know
it was like wow
Bruno
after that we inserted this super dermal
implants in my forehead
and from that point on the project
really started to take life
and that's when we decided to do the the
character of red School
I want to get as far as I can go
I think the day I stopped
will be the day I die
I'll give up my name and give up my
legacy
there might be many who come after me
but I'm the first person in the world to
achieve what I've achieved you know what
I mean and today I am proud to be
recognized as one of the only human
beings to have successfully embody the
cartoon character
I have an excellent relationship with my
son he sees me as a superhero as a super
dad
because of things Beyond My Control we
have been separated from each other for
about a year and a half two years now
but now very soon we'll be back together
at the moment thank God I've got him in
Colombia he is with his mother he is
super happy I talked to him every day by
video call
he's a kid who until now
loves me cares about me and respects me
[Music]
it is so I'm from maracai from a very
poor neighborhood
for me Venezuela
is the best you can get in the world
right now my country is going through
Nevada
[Music]
but at some point we can get out of this
anarchistic dictatorship and I can go
back to my country to contribute to
bringing it back to its former glory
[Music]
[Music]
wouldn't even think twice about it if
they fix my country no matter where I am
whatever part of the world at that
moment I'll go straight back I really
miss it
uh my mother died when I was very young
when I was roughly 15 or 16 years old
[Music]
it was an impact
social and visual for all my family when
they saw me like this for the first time
but of course I've always had this
obsession with tattooing
since I was very young
there are members of my family who
support me and others who are against it
[Music]
I'm not learning for a while this is my
business
he has breakfast here lunch you know
that's how I know him and from that we
became friends
well I've never seen someone that looked
like that before
so yeah it could surprise me but you
know nothing more lots of people have
tattoos and things like that
maybe I had never seen someone who look
quite like him so yeah I suppose I was a
bit surprised but now you know I'm used
to it
and he knows how to treat people
properly a good person I consider him a
good man
look he's like
I don't believe that
my modifications make me any more or
less
able to interact with people every day
[Music]
actually I believe what I am doing with
my body is not so that other people can
understand me but rather so I can
understand other people is to
demonstrate to people that we can't
judge by appearances if your whole life
you have thought that the devil is red
with horns and Retail then dude I
admired you because that's what a
five-year-old thinks
foreign
[Music]
foreign